E aí
e eu poderia dizer que eu que me
proponho a fazer aqui agora seria uma
aula de cidadania de 18 minutos a
respeito de um assunto premente e
recente
e eu vou passar um vídeo de 6 minutos e
meio
no processo de votação tradicional onde
o voto que é um registro simbólico
precisa ser registrado em um suporte
físico nas cédulas de papel por exemplo
a urna cumpre a função de armazenar
entre a tapas do processo de votação
esses registros com garantias
suficientes e adequadas para as regras
que são aceitas pela sociedade por quem
organiza o sistema com algumas garantias
que precisam ser fiscalizados
de que os votos vão ser um por eleitor
abro a votar e que não vão ser mudados
entre o momento em que ele é sufragado
em que o eleitor deposita e o momento em
que ele é contado
e o que acontece com a informatização
são duas coisas importantes mudam a
forma em que o voto é registrado e a
novidade com o nosso sistema de votação
É que o voto agora passa a ser contado
dentro da urna Por Cada sessão essa seta
Redonda que vocês estão vendo aqui tá
indicando que são vários eleitores
depositando votos numa urna e e várias
Runas produzem resultados parciais
chamados boletins de urna que precisam
ser somados para dar o resultado da
eleição o que acontece quando uma urna
passa não só a coletar e armazenar votos
mas também A somar de uma maneira
eletrônica é que o eleitor perde a
capacidade de acompanhar essa Contagem
local a contagem dentro da urna tá então
a garantia que era antes possível com
alguma forma de Direito de eleitore
candidato acompanhar o processo de
Contagem precisa ser o instituído por
alguma outra forma de garantir Ok então
ação fiscalizatória que antes podia ser
acompanhado por qualquer um sem
especialidade técnica que ia saber se
voto estão sendo montados corretamente
os estão sendo depositado sem o devido
motivo um eleitor identificado para
votar uma vez só né precisa ser trocado
agora por uma maneira de validar que o
software que vai fazer a contagem o
programa de computador que vai rodar
dentro da Ana para fazer essa Contagem
tá contando corretamente É bem a questão
é que ninguém sabe quem é que faz essa
verificação
todos pensam que alguém outra pessoa tá
fazendo e no final ninguém faz agora
porque ninguém faz é parte da história
que eu tenho para contar para vocês ok
eu somos que já tentou fazer então tô
falando de uma posição de quem
experimento né nem
e a partir do momento em que as pessoas
passam a se acostumar com a ideia de que
o processo agora não mais permite o tipo
de fraude que ele conhece que é
manipulação de célula manipulação de
mapa né que eram formas visíveis e de
varejo de manipular uma eleição
algo estranho começa a acontecer com
eleitor e com os partidos que é eles
Passarem a entender o processo de
votação como algo parecido a um vídeo
game
bom
então com isso o processo eleitoral aos
poucos foi sendo direito de fiscalização
que o eleitor e os partidos normalmente
tinham em outras etapas do processo de
votação além daquele que acontece dentro
da urna
e o que em 2006 foi ressuscitado um tal
de comitê interpartidário para receber
material que permite a validar se a
contagem feita ninguém sabe onde para
totalização dos boletins de urna em
formato eletrônico que saem da zona
cepção somados para serem divulgados na
televisão e nos telões
o direito de acompanhar essa soma de
totalização convalidação com verificação
no correspondente
boletim impresso que deveria sair para
fiscais de partido interessados de cada
urna começou a ser silenciado em 2006
com a invenção desse comitê
interpartidário
basicamente sob o pretexto de que pode
faltar papel na impressora da urna eles
limitam o número de cópias de boletins
de urna que fiscais de partido podem
coletar na seção eleitoral assinada pelo
mesário e
é isso
partidos que podem estar Marcados para
serem prejudicados na eleição podem
ficar sem ter meio de prova de que a
totalização está correta Ok em 2016 vai
ser o direito do eleitor e dos partidos
de fiscalizar que a identificação do
eleitor está sendo correta porque o
motivo da biometria está sendo
introduzida na identificação de
eleitores a real a verdadeira não é que
está na propaganda né o papel que ela
exerce ao final vamos ver é o contrário
do que a propaganda anuncia
a propaganda oficial bem mas como é que
as pessoas se acostumam com esse
cerceamento Então por que que eu estou
aqui falando isso para vocês o que que
eu fui citado porque eu sou membro do
comitê multidisciplinar independente
formado por acadêmicos juristas e
técnicos de informática que presta o
serviço a partir e já tentaram consertar
as coisas que consideramos que estão
erradas no nosso processo de votação e
que perceberam que a dificuldade é muito
grande porque ela tem barreiras
institucionais e culturais para fazer a
sua voz ser ouvida suas ideias serem
levadas a sério né as suas queixas e as
Suas críticas
é bem para piorar
e essa situação de desinformação e
confusão o sistema
do ponto de vista de quem está
interessado em uma eleição limpa não é
tudo
e o sistema faz parte de um processo
então o sistema precisa ser desenvolvido
precisa ser preparado e carregado nos
respectivos equipamentos
é bem o motivo pelo qual ninguém mais de
Fora fiscaliza é porque e não a eficácia
nenhuma em O que é permitido legalmente
a quem for de fora do da
autoridade encarregada de desenvolver
preparar e executar eleição
verificasse o que tá disponível para
exame é exatamente o que está
funcionando no dia da eleição
bom então por que que é perigosa essa
confusão
entre urna sistema e processo
é porque é diante dessa confusão que
funciona algo na mente humana que são os
efeitos
ilusionistas
que pode ser aplicado numa situação como
essa também
e olha aqui
como se o sistema o processo fosse
apenas esse objeto de fetiche
Oi e o efeito pode estar sendo esse
e quem quer eleição limpa tá pensando em
segurança de que
Cuidado para não confundir
e a segurança a com a segurança B
e as duas podem ser a mesma se os
objetivos de ambos numa eleição Quem
opera o sistema e quem quer eleição
limpa coincidirem mas se não conheci
dhiren os mecanismos para garantir o
objetivo de cada um
e são diferentes e apenas um deles vai
poder prevalecer
tá bem porque que temos um sistema que
não permite fiscalização eficaz
principalmente por não permitir
recontagem de certa forma porque Paramos
no tempo na evolução
do processo de informatização São e
leitor ao
provavelmente ou Muito provavelmente
vocês vão ver esse tipo de explicação em
propaganda oficial em veículos da mídia
corporativa mas é um trabalho que vem
sendo desenvolvido na área acadêmica sou
professor de segurança na informática 17
anos na UnB mora em Brasília e tem o
privilégio então de poder acompanhar de
perto
essas coisas que acontecem lá
e a respeito do autoridade eleitoral
então o que que se percebeu que
com a informatização que parece estar
fazendo mágica ao tirar as formas de
fraude que existiam no papel
eliminá-las completamente
elas pagam preço para essa eliminação
que introduzir novas formas de fraude
essas invisíveis e praticáveis por
atacado e se não houver um mecanismo
independente do software para verificar
se a contagem está correta e rastreáveis
então o Brasil não foi o primeiro país
que informatizou eleições se você ouvir
isso não é verdade o primeiro foi a
Holanda em 91 depois seguido da índia em
92 ambas com o mesmo tipo de
informatização modelo Dr é que não
permite a recontagem faz a contagem
eletrônica na Urbano e esse percebeu que
essa concentração de riscos não era boa
para a segurança a a do eleitor que quer
eles são limpa e
reproduziram a trilha material o
registro do voto para permitir a
validação da Contagem eletrônica mas
cada vez que uma nova tecnologia
eleitoral introduzida no processo de
votação Ela traz consigo riscos
inerentes a ela e no caso das urnas no
modelo vvt vou trazer with wallpaper
Tree O problema é que as fraudes antigas
de papel
de novo estão
presentes o risco delas ocorrerem na
forma de manipulação das sacolas
contendo os registros de voto sejam
votos impressos sejam votos marcados a
caneta para serem escaneados
então a evolução não parou aí porque
quando acontece discrepância entre a
contagem manual para validar a contagem
eletrônica por amostragem EA Contagem
eletrônica que é que sai primeiro
tá em qual confiar qual das duas
deve prevalecer
e como no sistema de segunda geração as
trilhas de Custódia de voto eletrônica e
manual são independentes a questão fica
em aberto do ponto de vista do que que o
processo e o sistema podem oferecer de
garantia Daí até ser a geração de
sistema de votação
o que
fazem com que as duas trilhas sejam
criadas e mantidas de maneira Inter
conectada para que qualquer falha O
desvio o erro na contagem de votos em
uma das trilhas ela consiga a outra
trilha consigo apontar onde ocorreu o
erro e assim recuperar a contagem
correta em muitos casos exceto no voto
que deu problema em um voto só e não e
seções inteiras ou zonas eleitorais
inteiras então com base nisso eu resolvi
introduzir na literatura uma
classificação assim como existe para
celulares para sistemas de votação e
gerações baseado no fato de que esses
modelos surgiram ao longo do tempo para
resolver problemas que eram considerados
inerentes ao modelo mais novo anterior e
nessa ordem cronológica isso não é
fantasia e se existe na realidade
é
tão aqui as duas máquinas de primeira
geração que não envolvem registro
material do voto desenvolvidas para a
Holanda e para a Índia em 91 92 a
Holanda quando percebeu O perigo com as
máquinas de votar de primeira geração
abandonou a votação eletrônica voltou a
votação manual sim como a Alemanha já
índia continua com o sistema de primeira
geração até 2013 até mais ou menos
setembro de 2013 corte Suprema da Índia
declarou inconstitucional máquina de
votar que não permite a recontagem as
máquinas de segunda geração que eu posso
mostrar como exemplo são essas aqui da
Venezuela que imprimir o voto que o
eleitor tem que pegar e colocar numa
urna de papel a urna de papelão que
recebe o voto em papel essa algumas
seções eleitorais
essas urnas e contadas para ver se bate
com a contagem eletrônica no caso da
doméstica o eleitor não tem assim como
seria do Brasil em 2002 não tem contato
com o voto ele cai direto no receptáculo
que Para efeito de auditoria algumas são
abertas e contadas para ver se a
contagem física bate com a eletrônica
que são os sistemas de terceira geração
eu tenho a cartela do sistema argentino
aí quem quiser ver depois aqui dentro
tem um rfd que registra eletronicamente
o voto ao mesmo tempo em que no verso
dessa cartela o registro do voto é
impresso para que o eleitor possa
passando a cartela na frente do leitor
vê que a contagem eletrônica do voto
dele conhecido com até impressa a
cartela e qual depositado numa urna na
apuração as cartelas são passadas uma
uma aqui em cima todo mundo pode
acompanhar que a contagem está sendo
correta ao final é gravado um outra
cartela para boletim de urna cada a
receber uma cópia e cada boletim de urna
TAM aviação eletrônica e impressa que
vão para totalização essa aqui é uma
máquina que usa tecnologia criptográfica
redes mixmesh compro protocolo de
criptografia probabilística e não usa o
recurso dfdd integral registro material
com eletrônico e no Brasil no Brasil um
jogo de queda de braço entre o
legislativo eo judiciário para
avançarmos da primeira geração até a
segunda mas a cada movimento em direção
a
evoluímos nosso sistema de votação para
permite recontagem a um retrocesso
inicialmente no prótese legislativo essa
lei aqui por exemplo ela foi capitaneada
no senado na comissão de constituição e
justiça do Senado pelo Senador
Demóstenes Torres e aprovada Conde a
porta da comissão de ciência e
tecnologia direto ao plenário para
votação urgência urgente urgente urgente
mesmo do deputado João Paulo Cunha então
vocês podem ter uma ideia de conflito de
interesse em relação à evolução do nosso
sistema de votação e por último problema
foi no Supremo foi declarado em
inconstitucional a lei que
introduziria de volta aos disso material
do voto a pretexto de que quebrar o
sigilo do voto quando na verdade o teste
2012 mostrou que o que estava quebrando
o sigilo do voto era justamente o
substituto
eletrônico foi colocado a no lugar do
voto impresso para permitir Auditoria do
tipo assim você vale de uma nota fiscal
comparando ela com a cópia xerox dela
esse tal do RD ver né que foi
desmascarado a função dele em 2012 bem
então Oi gente o que eu tenho de
apresentar de novidade essa tendência
por quê que acontece de forma diferente
a informatização eleitoral em diversos
países Depende de aqui ela serve se ela
serve a uma a resolução de conflito
entre poderes republicanos
dentro do organismo político que se
oxide se considera uma democracia
em situações podem ocorrer nesse
conflito ou legislativo prevalece
o ou o poder constituído para executar e
julgar eleições concentro os poderes
sobre o processo eleitoral em si mesmo e
ele passa a prevalecer
ou então como é nos Estados Unidos o
conflito pulveriza soluções ao nível
mundo estadual e municipal Ok bem qual é
a nossa situação de concentração
absoluta
manifesta no fato de que Metade dos
juízes do Supremo Tribunal Federal São
juízes do Tribunal Superior Eleitoral
também então o que seria o último
recurso do Judiciário para
impedir abusos de poder de quem organiza
a eleição executa Julga os seus próprios
atos
eu não encontro as respaldo sucesso ou é
porque o julgamento ocorre num contexto
de
conflito de interesses sempre Ok e o que
a gente vê na prática uma teoria
esquizofrênica da prova judicial para
fins eleitorais se é para provar que tá
tudo certo basta o que diz a propaganda
é mencionado na sentença tá tudo bem
quando é para provar que alguma coisa
está errada se você não demonstrar que
houve prejuízo no resultado da eleição
arquivos
vale-tudo do da jurisprudência da prova
documental é isso que eu tinha dizer Ok
muito obrigado a todos
E aí